what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder i'm your host
warren thompson and we finally have our
very first episode of
moon night moon night stephen grant and
mark spector are now officially
introduced into the mcu and i'm going to
break down this very first episode for
you telling you everything you need to
know about steven grant mark spector
moon knight and the villain arthur what
he's up to what are his master plans and
what is in store for moon night there's
a lot to break down so let's dive right
into it but of course if you're new be
sure to subscribe so you don't miss out
on any of the latest marvel news so moon
knight episode 1 starts off with a black
screen but we hear music over the black
screen which is the song every grain of
sand by bob dylan we then see a person
who is doing some type of ritual they
never show this person's face but they
do show him with long hair and a staff
walking away now of course later on in
the episode we find out that this is
ethan hawk's character arthur harrow and
he seems to be doing some sort of a
ritual now in this episode we learn a
little bit about the mcu's arthur harrow
who doesn't seem to really be like his
character in the comics in fact arthur
harrow in the comics isn't even that big
of a moon knight villain arthur harrow
was a talented surgeon and scientist
whose work in medicine and pain
treatment led to him being nominated for
a nobel prize however a person by the
name of dr victoria grail became a
little bit suspicious on how his work
advanced since his research paper said
that he only carried out limited
research done on animals however she
linked him back to performing secret
experiments at auschwitz-birkenau a
famous concentration camp from real life
arthur of course wants to continue his
experiments and dr victoria grail wants
to stop him his men almost kidnap her
but moon knight interferes and saves her
the two of them then go to his lab to
try and stop him but he ends up getting
away and that's pretty much all the
interaction they had so as you can see
from this episode they have clearly
changed who this person is from the
comics which is actually something ethan
hawk said attracted him to this
character it was so new and everything
is so detached from the mcu there aren't
really that many connections being made
at least in the first few episodes but
there are some really important things
to notice in this opening scene now
ethan hawke said that he came up with
this ritual idea himself he said he was
always hypnotized by deeply spiritual
people who were self-lacerating and in
this scene here that's what we see him
do as a deeply spiritual person cult
leader and follower of the goddess of
myth he himself is self-lacerating when
we see him crush up the glass put the
glass in his shoes and walks on them but
two major important things here take a
look at the staff that he has it has two
crocodile heads on it and amit's head is
a crocodile head now we do know that he
uses this staff to judge people on
behalf of ahmed using her powers so he
was most likely given this staff by amit
herself or he found it in her tomb
somewhere we'll have to wait and see on
that however it goes with the tattoo on
his arm which is a scale now this scale
is an ancient egyptian scale used by the
god anubis during what was called the
weighing of the heart anubis was the
ancient egyptian god of the dead and the
wayne of somebody's heart would judge
their fate anubis would put the heart of
the deceased person on the scale and a
feather on the other side which
represented ma'at the goddess of truth
and justice if the heart was heavier
than the feather of ma'at it was
rejected and then eaten by ahmed the
devourer of souls and this is pretty
much what we see here in this episode of
moon night later on in the episode we
see arthur judge people's hearts he
explains that he has some of the power
of omit so it seems as if omit is
judging people but not when they're dead
when they're alive more on this in a bit
when we get to the scene after the
opening scene the marvel logo plays and
we hear the song a man without love
which is pretty reflective on how steven
grant feels in life steven wakes up in
bed and we see a shot of the rubik's
cube that we see in a later on scene we
know he uses this as a puzzle to help
him stay awake at night now originally
when we first see this scene we don't
really know what's going on he has a
restraint on his leg there's sand all
around his bed and there's tape on his
door now eventually we go on to find out
when he's talking to his friend the
golden man that his body at night just
has to get up and walk about he doesn't
remember anything when this happens
which is why he tries to stay awake and
which is why he puts these restraints on
him so he doesn't actually go anywhere
this is also why he has the sand around
his bed and the tape on his door if he
gets up and goes somewhere he'll leave
footprints in the sand and he'll know in
the morning if he left or not also the
tape on the door will be broken so he'll
know if he left his flat so the first
thing he does when he wakes up in the
morning is check his restraint check the
sand and check the door after this he
feeds his fish who only has one fin and
notice there is a little statue of a
pyramid inside of the fish tank perhaps
this is something later or perhaps it's
just a decoration he then calls his mom
and leaves her voicemail we hear him
joke about taking his fish somewhere
nice but then we hear him say that he
wakes up every morning feeling like he
got hit by a bus we don't know it at the
time but of course eventually we find
out that this is actually mark spector
taking over his body and becoming moon
knight going around and getting in
fights which is why steven's body hurts
all the time but of course like he said
and like we go on to find out he has
zero recollection of this so he doesn't
actually know what's happening not yet
at least we then follow steven to work
and we learn a little bit about him we
learned that he's a pretty passive guy a
nice guy who doesn't really want any
confrontation a guy that's tired all of
the time because he tries to stay up at
night because his body goes off and does
whatever it wants so we see him tired on
the bus falling asleep on top of
strangers we follow steven to work and
we find out that he works at a very
famous london museum the british museum
in which right now they are doing an
ancient egypt showcase and when he gets
to work we kind of see his knowledge
about ancient egypt a little girl puts
trash inside of a pyramid display and
steven takes this opportunity to teach
her a little bit about ancient egypt and
this part is important and it's related
to the scale he explains that if you
take a hook and you put it down the nose
you pull it out all the organs come out
except for the heart because the ancient
egyptians believed that they needed the
heart to be judged in the underworld and
this is what i was talking about in the
beginning anubis would judge them with
their hearts on one side of the scale
and the feather of ma'at on another if
rejected amit would eat their hearts the
little girl asked if it hurt being
rejected in which he says that doesn't
make sense because he's alive and we'll
come back to this very specific point in
just a bit now we find out that despite
him having a vast amount of knowledge on
ancient egypt he doesn't have a very
good job at the museum and a lot of
people treat him like crap calling him
by the wrong name most of the time
however a bit of good news happens a
female co-worker comes up to him and
asks him if they're still on for stakes
that night now steven has no idea what
she's talking about because as we go to
find out it's actually mark who made
that date or perhaps another personality
that's inside of him that hasn't been
revealed yet but regardless it wasn't
him that made the date which is why he's
so confused and to top it all off he's a
vegan and they're going out for steaks
now in the back steven is working with
his boss who treats him like absolute
crap and even when he is showing how
much knowledge he has on ancient egypt
she still kind of refuses to listen and
still rejects him being a tour guide
which just crushes his soul and is sad
to watch but he talks about the any ad
and as steven states the ineod has nine
members not seven like the poster show
but what's really interesting is that
these nine deities are grouped with the
creation of our world it kind of makes
you think a little bit about the
infinity stones maybe there's a
connection here with gods we'll have to
wait and see in fact the moon knight
comics actually talk about the inead now
the inead gods the nine gods in which
steven grant mentions here are actual
characters in marvel comics known as the
heliopolitans and they exist in a place
called celestial hilliar palace which is
a city and it's in an extra dimensional
realm and in the comics konshu is one of
these heliopolitans also side note bast
the black panther god is also a
heliopolitan as well so there is a
little bit of a black panther connection
here so i would not be surprised if we
did see these inead gods in the future
in the mcu the next scene we see stephen
talking to his golden friend where he
explains that he's got a date with the
girl from work and he doesn't know how
it happened because he didn't even ask
her out and of course we know it was
mark or another personality he also
states that if he is going to have a
girlfriend one day he can't be having
ankle restraints on his bed so he has to
figure something out now from here we go
back to mark's flat we see his nightly
routine his routine of trying to stay
awake because as we know sometimes when
he's asleep his body does what it wants
at least that's what he thinks it is but
it's really mark getting up as we
mentioned before he pours the sand
around his bed puts the tape on the door
grabs his rubik's cube and puts on audio
that helps him stay awake from here we
see what he does to stay awake in which
one big thing that he does is he
actually studies egyptian mythology
specifically what he mentioned before
the iniad which says is a rift between
god and man which of course is setting
up what is about to happen because he is
about to hear the voice of konchu the
god of the moon soon because the next
scene that we see is of steven lying on
the grass he gets up and the first thing
he notices is that his jaw is super
messed up but he manages to put it back
in place his teeth are bloody you can
tell that he just fought he asked what
happened and he finds himself in the
alps having no idea how he got there and
then he hears a voice the voice says go
back to sleep worm stephen looks around
and sees no one and then he hears the
voice again saying you're not supposed
to be here steven says that he agrees
and continues to look for the voice but
cannot find it and here's where we hear
the voice say surrender the body to mark
and mark of course is mark spector now
in the comics mark spector is actually
the true person moon knight mark specter
is the main person and stephen grant is
a personality of mark spector more on
who mark is in just a bit now steven has
no idea what the voice is talking about
when he says surrender the body and we
hear the voice call stephen an idiot
saying the idiot is in control meaning
that steven right now is in control of
the body and not mark spectre now the
voice talking is the egyptian moon god
konchu and in the comics mark spector is
the avatar for konchu so basically mark
spector does the will of konchu now
steven then finds a scarab with egyptian
markings on it in his pocket and we very
very briefly see the moon god konchu
behind him now steven senses his
presence but when he turns around he's
not there he does however see some
people in a window who start to fire at
him and then he runs away until he
eventually finds himself in a city he
blends in with the crowd until we
eventually meet ethan hawk's character
arthur harrow now the people of this
town worship arthur praising him and
touching him as he goes by he says it's
a beautiful day and it feels like heaven
but it's not sometimes there's darkness
hiding in people's hearts and this is a
direct call to the wane of the hearts
and the judgment that he is about to do
he asks who would like to be judged and
one person steps up and is deemed good
another woman steps up and says i must
know and we see that in this process the
cane moves back and forth kind of like a
scale would also the scale on his hand
shows us the end result green for good
red for bad it was green for the first
guy deeming him good but unfortunately
it shows up red for this lady deeming
her bad now here's where this gets kind
of interesting and this is a very
important part the lady says i've been
good my whole life in which arthur
replies i believe you but the scales see
everything perhaps it's something that
lies ahead meaning she is going to go on
to do something evil in the future and
ahmet is judging her now now this is
actually further explained by arthur in
the last part of this episode when
talking to stephen in the museum stephen
says i don't have your beetle in which
arthur replies oh the scarab doesn't
belong to me it belongs to amit do you
know her now it shows a picture of ahmet
on the wall now ahmet in ancient
egyptian text and on this picture here
has the head of a crocodile the front
legs and torso of a lion in the back
legs and the rear end of a hippopotamus
these are the three largest man-eating
animals known to ancient egyptians and
stephen even says here ahmet the first
known boogeyman in which arthur replies
she was only a boogeyman for evil doers
and this is the important part he says
that she ahmet grew weary of waiting for
sinners to have to commit their crimes
before punishing them he also says that
she sees all of people's lives their
past present and future meaning that she
could see the sins that they will do in
the future so what is happening is that
now instead of ahmet judging people
after they're dead she is judging them
while they're alive using arthur but the
plan is here to free her in the scene
where he judges the man who is deemed to
be good he says that he's brave wanting
to serve our goddess even before she
wakes then when he's with stephen in the
museum at the end he says if ahmet had
been free she would have prevented
hitler and other horrible people and
events so this is what arthur's plan is
to free ahmed so she can judge the world
herself and not have to use him as what
we presume is an avatar because he goes
on to talk about avatars which we'll
talk about in a bit now after the lady
dies one of arthur's men says that they
had a problem with the exchange and they
got ambushed and that somebody came and
killed two of their men and that means
they didn't get the scarab but arthur is
very very clever in this next scene he
asks if he's still there in which he
says i believe so so he calls out to the
crowd dua amamit now in arabic the word
dua means a prayer of invocation or a
supplication request or calling out to
god so when he says dua ammamit in which
we know amit is the goddess that he
worships and he serves so i assume that
this phrase that he speaks is something
like praise amit and this immediately
makes everybody fall to their knees we
assume to praise ahmet but of course
steven grant here doesn't know what that
means so he is the last to get to his
knees which obviously shows that he is a
person out of place which means he is
the person that ambushed arthur's men
really genius move here now when arthur
sees him he says i know you mercenary in
which stephen grant says no i'm not a
mercenary i work at a gift shop now the
mercenary is actually mark spector that
is what mark spectre was before mark
spector became moon knight he was a
mercenary and he was on a job in sudan
where a fellow mercenary of his bushmen
killed an archaeologist in front of the
archaeologist's daughter he was appalled
and he fought bushmen but he lost he's
left for dead but right before he dies
he finds himself before the statue of
the egyptian moon god konchu he then
actually dies but is suddenly revived
fully healed he claims konshu
resurrected him wanting him to be the
moon's knight and the left fist of
khanshu however a lot of people don't
really know if mark's telling the truth
or if he's actually crazy and is making
this up in his mind but mark spector is
a mercenary and it seems like mark
spector has run into arthur before which
is why arthur recognizes him
unfortunately stephen grant has no idea
about any of this and arthur doesn't
know that mark stephen has dissociative
identity disorder so he thinks steven is
really mark just kind of messing with
him but arthur says well steven grant of
the gift shop will you return the scarab
and of course steven is like sure yeah i
don't care i don't even know what this
is i don't know how i'm here so he tries
to give it to him but then we get a very
eddie brock and venom type of moment and
kanchu even kind of sounds like venom
here let's be honest steven goes to give
him the scarab but konshu takes control
over his body and closes his hand steven
has no idea what is going on is very
confused and he's trying to tell arthur
this he's trying to tell him i didn't do
this i have no control over my body
right now i'm trying to give it to you
just take it but here we can see kind of
the power that konchu has over stephen
and he may or may not have this power
over mark specter mark spector's mind
might be a little bit more harder to
break then again they are kind of the
same person so who knows so kanchu won't
let steven give arthur the scarab so
arthur's men jump on him but then
stephen's eyes kind of go into the back
of his head where he kind of falls
asleep for a brief moment wakes back up
to see that he is really beating the
crap out of these men just take a look
at some of these guys on the floor we
can see blood coming out of their heads
on the ground this is kind of something
we haven't really seen from marvel we
haven't seen much blood coming out of
people in marvel and steven's hand is
holding the scarab and is super bloody
and he has no idea what just happened
because mark briefly took over mark and
stephen are both fighting to use the
body so steven comes back is super
confused and realizes what he did and he
needs to run so he runs and conscious
says don't you dare give up the scarab
steven says okay he gets in a van starts
to drive away now of course they all
start to chase him and steven is
uttering this has to be a dream and from
here we get a pretty cool scene with a
little questionable cgi at the end but
during the scene every time it seems
like steven is about to die mark spector
comes out now we don't see what mark
specter does but we do see the aftermath
when stephen comes back each time and
each time we see that mark has took care
of business every time mark comes out he
gets rid of some people until the very
end where stephen comes back and he's
actually driving backwards he also
realizes that he has a gun in his hand
in which he throws it at the car in
which conscious says did he just throw
the gun so kanchi was actively speaking
to mark during this whole entire thing
steven says i don't know what i'm doing
so conscious says well then leave us be
of course speaking about him and mark he
manages to turn the car around but then
the car dies in which two people get out
of the car they're about to go up to
stephen but then the truck that was
carrying the wooden logs at the top of
the mountain they've finally reached the
bottom and they kill the two guys mark
then immediately wakes up in a panic but
then he looks around sees that the
restraint is still around his leg and
kind of laughs it off going wow that was
actually just a dream a very realistic
dream now here's something very
interesting steven checks the normal
things that he checks each morning the
sand and the door and if you notice the
tape was still on the door but clearly
mark spector just did a lot of stuff so
this means that mark knows exactly what
steven does and then he replaces it to
make it seem like nothing ever happened
at night when mark is up and about he
redoes the tape as we see here because
steven takes off the tape or is mark
spector possibly not real could konchu
and mark spector all be inside steven's
head this will be revealed in future
episodes now steven's eating cereal
talking to his fish gus when he notices
something very strange he takes him to
the pet store freaked out because gus
only had one fin in the beginning and
now he magically has two but he finds
out that he was actually in the fish
store yesterday buying a fish in which
stephen has no recollection of at all
which means it was mark now what
happened to the fish i have no idea it
clearly died because mark or another
personality clearly had to go buy a new
fish to replace gus with but
unfortunately steven doesn't have much
time to talk about it as he realizes
that he has a date or at least he had
one at the restaurant it looks like he's
getting stood up so he calls the girl in
which she says that she was waiting for
him on friday but it's now sunday she
hangs up saying lose my number and
steven still can't believe it he asked
the waiter what day it is and he
confirms it is sunday now stephen is
super upset at this point and you just
feel so bad for him he's so upset that
he even orders a steak despite the fact
that he's a vegan and he has no idea how
to order a steak the waiter asks him
what kind of cud he wants he says the
best part he asked him how he wants it
done he tells him good you just feel so
bad for the guy and you feel even worse
in the next scene where you see that he
brought flowers he has heart candies and
he's on the phone with his mom and he's
lying to her telling her that the date
went well and that he thinks his mom
would really like her and he'll bring
her around soon now back at steven's
flat he's super down he's eating the
chocolates that he bought for the grill
he gives gus the fish a few of the
sprinkles from the chocolates but then
he drops them and he notices some
markings on the floor he notices that it
looks like the table has been scooted
over and back over several times to
leave these marks on the floor so he
lifts up the rug he sees more markings
so he investigates he moves the table
over to where it looks like it's always
been moved to and he finds a secret
compartment that has a phone in it with
a charger and a key to something he
charges the phone turns it on and sees
that he has a ton of missed calls from
somebody named layla now all of the
calls are from layla except for number
32 you see the name duchamp and this is
very important because this is jean-paul
duchamp john paul duchamp was a french
soldier and pilot and he was a mercenary
and while he was a mercenary he actually
befriended mark spector the two of them
became close friends and mark ended up
calling john paul frenchy frenchie was
actually with mark in sudan where he
tried to attack bushmen and failed and
almost died while he did die and then
conscious revived him eventually mark
and frenchie run into each other again
and frenchie is shocked to see mark
alive and from there on out he helps
mark with his moon night operations he
is basically if moon knight is batman
alfred he's moon knight's alfred so i'm
assuming we'll see jean paul duchamp
probably pop up pretty soon now as he's
about to call leyla she actually calls
him he picks up and we find out that
layla has been texting and calling him
for months not knowing if he was alive
of course he has no idea who she is so
she's very confused and she says what is
going on with you mark and this really
shocks steven and he asks why did you
call me mark she eventually hangs up and
he tries to call her back but then he
hears a different voice than konchu a
voice calling out stephen he looks
around calls out hello but there's no
one in sight in which the voice
continues to say steven you need to stop
you're gonna get yourself in trouble but
steven doesn't believe this and he says
someone's having a laugh meaning
someone's kind of playing a prank on him
but he traces the voice to the bathroom
in which he looks in the mirror gets
scared for a second but realizes that
he's just looking at his reflection
however as he keeps staring into it the
reflection starts to shake its head no
and since steven isn't shaking his head
this obviously is of major concern so he
turns the light on in which just a
normal reflection is revealed but the
lights in the apartment start to flicker
and then he turns around but his
reflection does not turn around and
continues to stare at him and then it
calls to him and he says steven in which
stephen turns around and he says stop
looking now this is mark spector mark is
telling steven to stop looking into the
affairs of mark then the entire flat
starts to shake like it's an earthquake
books and items are falling off the
shelves everything's moving and steven
runs out of the flat and he runs to the
elevator now steven in the elevator
turns around looks in the mirror and he
kind of checks out his own reflection he
touches it to make sure he's not going
crazy the elevator opens up to the third
floor steven kind of stares down the
hall and then he hits the g for ground
button in the elevator but then the
elevator opens up again on floor two and
stephen looks down the hall and then
konshu appears he fades in and out until
eventually gets right up to the elevator
in which right when he gets to the
elevator it's actually revealed to be an
old woman but steven is terrified and he
falls to the floor and he freaks the
woman out even though he says oh i've
lost a contact she is still super
freaked out and kind of threatened by
him now the elevator opens back up on
the fifth floor in which stephen is
really concerned about what is going on
but then he turns around and konshu is
right behind him but then he wakes up
and he's on the bus and here's where
stuff really starts to go down he's on
the bus and he looks out and he sees
konchu just on the street he then gets
off the bus and then he sees that arthur
was on the bus and this is where steven
really starts to freak out he goes in he
tells the security guard can you not let
anybody dodgy in his boss comes in
asking to take some stuff downstairs and
he actually stands up to her and says
can you just give me a minute because he
spotted somebody that was on the bus so
he goes and he follows that person and
eventually that person leads him to
arthur now arthur is kind of starting to
realize something is up and this isn't
the same person the same mercenary that
he ran into before he says so you really
do work at a gift shop stephen runs over
to a security guard named ronnie says
ronnie can you help me in which ronnie
pulls up his sleeve and reveals a scale
saying praise amit revealing that he
works with arthur and this is what we
talked about before where arthur is
serving amit she is not yet free but in
the meantime through him she is judging
people before they actually die steven
tries to run away but he keeps running
into more and more people that are with
arthur and then we find out that arthur
actually knows konchu is inside of
steven's head he mentions the voice in
his head and how it's relentless and
forever unsatisfied and eventually
arthur gets him and he says i'm trying
to help you and he starts to judge him
but here's what's very interesting the
scale doesn't go green or red not good
or bad but instead arthur looks at him
and says there is chaos in you now this
could mean several different things
which i'm sure they reveal but i'm
thinking that the chaos is definitely
all of the different personalities
inside of him now he gets lucky and a
tour comes in and he manages to escape
now this seems to be very shocking to
arthur and arthur actually tells
everybody to let him go now this is of
course because he has a plan stephen has
to work inventory because he was laid a
few times during the week and this is
where arthur is going to strike steven
is about to leave but he thinks he hears
a dog so he goes searching for it now as
he starts to search for this what he
assumes is a dog we can see in the
reflections of the glass mark spectre
and he realizes what's happening here
now he eventually runs into the dog but
then we see the shadow of it and he
realizes really really fast that this is
not a dog it's something way bigger and
a lot more monstrous he starts to hide
but then he hears over the intercom
arthur saying steven grant of the gift
shop give me the scarab and you won't be
torn apart steven throws his bag in an
attempt to distract what we thought
originally was going to be werewolf by
night we were wrong it's actually an
egyptian jackal it jumps out the bag but
then steven runs and it eventually
starts chasing him it jumps on him hurts
his arm just a little bit but eventually
steven runs into the bathroom and here
is the first time where we meet mark
spector once inside the bathroom mark
calls out to stephen from the mirror he
says steven i can save us but you can't
fight me this time i need full control
speaking about the body now steven
thinks he's going crazy he ignores his
moving reflection that is speaking to
him and he starts to slap himself and
then he says he's going to die now
eventually mark says look at me and
stephen does he tells him he's not going
to die let me save us and if you notice
there is no longer a reflection of
stephen in the mirrors and any of the
mirrors because it's kind of creating
like an infinite mirror here the
reflection is gone and it's just marked
that he sees in the mirror mark says let
me save us and steven finally gives in
and as steven starts to agree and mark
starts to take over you can see egyptian
markings and hieroglyphics in the
background kind of start to light up
steven shakes his head yes and all of a
sudden the reflection of mark is gone
it's back to the reflections of stephen
or now i should say mark and moon knight
comes out right as the moon knight
transformation begins the egyptian
jackal jumps in and attacks him however
the next thing that we see is the
egyptian jackal trying to get away
showing you just how strong moon knight
is and in this last scene we can see
moon knight does not hold his punches
and marvel is going to show us him not
holding his punches and the episode ends
with our first full look at moon knight
not that we didn't see it in the trailer
but it's first revealed in this episode
so what did you think about the very
first episode of moon night i thought it
was a great episode and i'm super
excited to see how this all ends so let
me know what you think in the comments
down below about the first episode of
moon night don't forget to like the
video and subscribe so you don't miss
out on any future moon night videos for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof